[Music]
we have a secretary of defense that
testified to congress in may that the
afghan national security force could
withstand the taliban advance we have
chairmans of joint chief who the command
is a member of that who's supposed to
advise on military policy
we have a marine combatant commander
all of these people are supposed to
advise potentially all those people did
die in vain if we don't have senior
leaders that own up and
raise their hand and say
we did not do this well in the end
well that man marine corps lieutenant
colonel stewart sheller is now sitting
in the brig and he faces a potential
court martial for calling out the sheer
ineptitude of this military
decision-making now
while he's in jail the craven leaders he
called out peddled excuses for their
failures in afghanistan on the hill
today
i recommended that we maintain 2 500
troops in afghanistan i also have a view
that the withdrawal of those forces
would lead inevitably to the collapse of
the afghan military forces
yes my assessment was uh
back in the fall of 20 and it remained
consistent throughout that we should
keep a steady state of 2500 and it could
bounce up to 3 500 maybe something like
that
well in the end did they agree with
what the young man was saying joining me
exclusively are lieutenant colonel
sheller's parents kathy and stu scheller
uh stu your reaction um to your son's
imprisonment
while our military leaders were you know
playing the kind of blame shifting game
on capitol hill today essentially saying
no we we would have left troops there
that was our recommendation your
response
our son called for accountability
and
throughout the hearing today i don't
feel like they accepted accountability
so i'm extremely disappointed
uh and it's it's no coincidence in my
opinion
that they put a gag order on him
and they put him in prison
the day before they had to appear
in front of senators and tomorrow in
front of congressmen
i think
i think that is fairly
an act of coward
cowardice and our son we're very proud
of our son our son is a hero
he fought for this country for 17 years
he's been on five deployments
he's taught countless men and women
the marines
thought him exemplary they have
fast-tracked him in his career
and until 30 days ago
he was a hero to the leadership of the
marine
corps but on
august 26th
when 13 of our servicemen died at the
kabul airport
something inside of our son
snapped
he was angry
and he
in principle he's a very courageous and
principled man always has been
but when that
he had to go and ask his
leaders for accountability
he had many he had many active duty
marines and there are many veterans out
here that that he works with
with suicide prevention that were asking
was it all worth it
and he called for accountability and
within 12 hours they removed him of his
position
and
after that
it's been downhill from there
kathy uh
your son
your son's in military prison tonight as
a mother
when you watch general mark milley ask
point blank
if he would resign
i want your reaction after we play his
answer
as a
senior military officer
resigning is a really serious thing it's
a political act if i'm resigning in
protest
my dad didn't get a choice to resign at
iwo jima and those kids there at abby
gate they don't get a choice to resign
and i'm not going to turn my back on
them uh i'm not going to resi they can't
resign so i'm not going to resign
there's no way
kathy he said resigning would be turning
his back on the troops
your thoughts
my thoughts are
our son
said to him if you thought this was a
bad idea
were you willing to take your rank and
put it down and say i will not put our
men and women in peril
he should have dropped that rank he
should have resigned and said i will not
do this to our service members
but he didn't do that did he and let me
explain to you why the accountability is
so important
during our war the last 20 years we have
lost around
7 000
troops
we have lost somewhere depending on the
data that you want to look at
somewhere in the last 20 years between
30 up to 100 000
troops
from suicide
they need that accountability
they need to know that what they did
mattered
so many lives can be saved
on the backside by being held
accountable
and i say take that rank and put it down
and stand up for your other service
members stand up for my son stand up for
stew stand up for america
stewart um basically
go ahead go
basically
they they left hundreds of americans in
afghanistan
where they're leaving our son tonight in
prison
and that's not okay with us
and
i challenge the american people is that
okay with you
is it okay with you
that a 17-year
infantry officer
that
put his life on the line
to protect you and protect your children
is it okay with you
that he is put in jail
and is facing a court martial he didn't
murder anyone he didn't sexually offend
anyone he didn't do drugs
he asked for accountability he spoke his
truth and they couldn't handle it
it's
an embarrassment it's shameful
and if it's not okay for you
americans we're asking you to stand up
write your congressman call your
congressman demand accountability
and it's not just accountability for the
botched afghanistan withdrawal and
americans left behind it's
accountability the only one that's being
held accountable
for this
botched
situation is my son by the generals
senator cohen did they asked yeah i want
to play this actually you took the words
out of my mouth senator cotton asked
defense secretary austin about your
son's confinement today watch
marine colonel stuart sheller posted a
very critical video on social media last
month and he was relieved of his command
for that posting uh media reports today
indicate that he is being held in
pre-trial confinement why is that
uh i i don't have any specifics of what
caused him to be held in pre-trial
confinement uh and i would def i would
uh certainly uh ask the marines to
provide
that insight
kathy he's the pentagon chief
he's
this young man is in jail in military
jail are you surprised that austin seems
to have no idea what's going on or
pretends he has no idea what's going on
i could not believe
i could not believe those words came out
of his mouth and if he doesn't know
what's going on shame on him
shame on him if he is totally unaware
a lot of other people are aware
but we are not going to let them take
their dirty little secret and hide it
away and put our son
so he can't speak put a gag order on him
take him away from his freedom of speech
so that they can hide their little
secret oh i i don't know huh no not i
don't know anything about it
well stuart joe biden campaigned for the
president who was going to bring
accountability and transparency to
government that was a big part of the
pitch also restoring dignity
uh to our national conversation bringing
us all together as a country that really
that was a big part of his
campaign against president trump to win
this uh election and you know he's he's
commander-in-chief now and and there the
counter-argument to this to play devil's
advocate is your son violated military
code by going public
with criticism of his commanders
according to the technical
uh military law that exists on the books
and your reaction
i get i get that lieutenant colonel
sheller
caused problems for the marine corps and
the military
by uh
breaking the chain of command
and
he knows it
and um
it it will be talked about for decades
in the future
of what stewart has done with social
media et cetera it's a problem for the
marine corps
but while stewart broke the chain of the
command
i contend
general mckenzie
general milley secretary austin
they have broken the chain of trust
and confidence of the american people
and for that
they should be embarrassed they should
drop their rank they should drop the
rank and they should resign for that
because today's hearings show that they
aren't going to accept accountability
for the mistakes they made they wanted
to blame everybody else the afghan
government the afghan military
the weather whoever forgetting
but i'm telling you uh
they should they should resign
because shouldn't they be fired i mean i
mean be honest
resign shouldn't they be fired
you know i i got to tell you uh you and
i both know joe biden isn't going to
fire him
so i'd like to just bring this back to
my son
this we have to get word out to the
american people as to what's going on
for him he needs our help
his family needs our help
and we're asking the american people to
write their congressmen and say if it's
not all right with them
then they want
we need you to say we want them to
resign we want stuart
sheller released we would like him to
have his pension reinstated his
hard-earned pension we would like him to
have his medical benefits that he is
going to need after the deployments that
he has endured but if they won't do that
at least release him and let him out of
the marines he has asked for that
and that's what we're asking for and
we're asking for people to support his
family by going to
pipehittersfoundation.org
there is a donate button up on the top
and you can hit who do we you know who
who do we donate for and you can find
our son lieutenant colonel stuart
sheller on there his family desperately
needs funding
um for him
now this is this is to live
legal fees
outrageous this is
the legal fees we're gonna we're gonna
work on that okay this is
ridiculous
this is a travesty what's happening to
your son
beyonce we would like to think this is
we would like to think this will be over
in days or weeks but we have been
our expectations have been leveled
by
stewart's legal team that
the marines could drag this out for
years
their their objective would be and by
the way
pre-top pre-trial confinement is a nice
comfortable
word is he a flight risk is your son is
your son a flight risk
absolutely no
he loves his country he loves america he
loves the marines so
he is they don't want him to talk
they're worried about what else he might
say
that's why they don't want him to talk
and they have not even brought charges
on him and they are holding him
in solitary confinement that's that's
not what they did if that's not okay
with
yeah that's that well they they did well
they seemed to like solitary confinement
lately you know all that all the human
rights civil rights folks used to say
solitary confinement was cruel and
unusual punishment but they love using
it as punishment against people they
think are political opponents that is
absolutely disgusting your son's state
of mind kathy as a mom what is it
tonight
i don't know i can't talk to him they
don't allow him to make phone calls
he we talked to him for two minutes on
monday morning when he asked us to
contact his attorney he got one phone
call we have had no communication with
him
this can't be our country and it's not
like the marine corps is calling us to
to let us know would this have happened
under president trump stuart
no no we would not have had the botched
exit under president trump
in my opinion uh but i i also and so i
don't think stu would have
done what he did and and and if we would
have been at this point president trump
would have stepped in if generals were
out of hand
yeah well this is a story that is not
going away sadly but uh i bet the
country is with you stu and kathy
we'll keep in touch with you and uh
we'll get those postings up on social
media uh on those other issues that you
were mentioning the help for the family
absolutely